alors pour ceux qui n'ont pas vu
l'émission la semaine dernière parce
qu'effectivement elle est pas passé deux
bonnes heures voici un petit best-of de
la semaine dernière et ça s'appelle tout
le monde en a parlé serge magnéto
même alain madelin aujourd'hui dit qu'il
faut fumer des pétards
non maire d'alma direct à topsy comme un
truc
aussi non vous ne l'aviez ça que vous
avez vous allez au massacre l'attendait
mais je pense que les choses changent
ouais parce que le 17 heures avec la
boutique du pollen du 0-0
est mort hélas jamais vous avez jamais
fumé jamais pu me thiam actuel jamais
été chi jamais et des deux labels
donnèrent jamais non jamais
vous avez encore le temps sur et oui
encore pourquoi est-ce que ça je suis
sûr vous avez fumé de la
bng pas pourquoi vous avez une tête
avant fumée de labeur ont en conséquence
ne peut pas pas très que tata pas des
boules de paille sur france 2 mai sur
tf1
il faut que je parle pour toi je te
piste à se questionner
j'aimerais bien venir mais pourquoi tu
ne reviens pas pour autant compte
affirme pourtant fermé des portes à rota
barrer le passage ça arrange pas mal de
gens que je ne sois pas minutes de cirer
les pompes mais je comprends pas moi non
plus
oui
le plaisir
qui va faire fureur c'est la panoplie
est le signe boutin je ne comprends pas
pourquoi sur toutes mes caricatures mais
des boucles d'oreilles je n'emporte
absolument jamais plus de style
les bébés phoques si c'est la libye pour
tout un tas de choses je gerbe et les
phoques à la croche pas même petit
vous connaissez fait c'est le butin et
la voilà non là on ne sait pas
qui travaillent
francis à ce que tu écoutes un peu à la
radio
ser la réponse est malheureusement que
le sport le foot
c'est une question très piège vous le
jurer de répondre vraiment
écouté c'est très simple en fonction de
tout ce qui a été dit un homme et un
homme qui vivent ensemble qui s'aiment
humainement moralement sexuellement ils
se font du bien ou du mal
je ne sais pas moi je pense que deux
hommes qui s'aiment et deux femmes qui
s'aiment moralement physiquement se font
du bien
[Musique]
est ce que est ce que vous trouvez ça
donne quand ils voyagent adore ses
général saison facile et un plus bas à
100 résume mon métier génial de sentir
bon j'essaye de voir si j'ai pas une
mouche non c'est sa toute façon mafia
compléments capillaires uniquement alors
c'est pour ça je te demanderai de
toucher uniquement cette partie là je te
remercie
quelles sont les armes de séduction vous
déployez consciemment le regard oui moi
aussi
j'ai
chassé aunis c'est madame char a fait
quelque chose mais sheila tranquille
donc
des soucis chez les beckham aux il
commence son père l'appelle comme ça
s'ils sont aptes à klang méfiez vous
est-ce que tu serais choqué si je
sortais avec ta fille
c'est une question ou une information
non c'est
sûrement nous appliquons petit ou
au musée haut musée bas
alors est ce que vous êtes volage je
suis marié ouais donc il est volage
chéries chéris
doudou en doute de wasit din din din din
mmm appelé titi web appelée gras double
parce qu'il était gros peut-être voilà
j'ai un peu gros il ya quand même les
mâles et les femelles je veux bien dans
la vie sexuelle ce qui veut dire c'est
que brûler pour l'évolution mais un
moment bon moi je suis plutôt attiré par
les femmes quoi aujourd'hui renault
aujourd'hui peut-être que vous pourriez
vous faire prendre pénétrer être passif
mais avec une femme voilà ça serait 12
heures
j'arrive et je
trouve très belle en ce moment là là
présentement l'a vraiment maison
ed du sud oui c'est normal une
portugaise et un réseau il est chaud
juste avant une petite pièce à titi
aussi
j'ai presque 40 ans c'est vrai comment
vous faites je baise
est-ce qu'ils étaient heureux benoît
delépine que lagaf a été élu
personnalité de l'année aux sept d'or
trouve souvent un vrai qu'on ne faut que
tu es aussi mais c'est l'interview
mensonge la merde non non non je ne le
pense pas une chose que j'aime bien je
vous adore la gaffe car mon meilleur ami
est ce que vous trouvez que ppda les
journalistes oui
alors que penses tu des 35 heures si je
suis comme je suis pas peur d'abord si
tu communiste eut commencé des princes
par camara
c'est la base c'est élémentaire
camarades ma fille je suppose
[Musique]
vous avez toujours des visayas et
d'affiner moi je vais vous dire ça c'est
des moments d'émotion avec comme c'est
comme ça c'est le jeu ce sont les
observer je ne sais pas vous caresser
les seins en venant ce matin
louis de fontenelle mari de geneviève
regarde à la télé le face-à-face giscard
mitterrand il manger une tartine de
confiture il meurt 16 mars 80 et avait
mis quoi dans la confiance
ah oui c'est vrai j'ai oublié que
j'étais
je me marre en vous regardant parce que
je pense que les gens chez eux se disent
est ce qu elle ressemble à birkin est ce
qu elle ressemble à jacques doillon un
peu des deux je pense et les oreilles de
serge gainsbourg ça je comprends pas
pourquoi
en politique aujourd'hui l'ennemi c'est
qui c'est la droite c'est la droite
c'est devedjian c'est le rpr
quand tu sais que tu es très chiant
quand tu es sérieux
il a dit je ne voudrais jamais les pieds
dans ses émissions de con way alors j'ai
retrouvé des petites notes où il a quand
même participé au palmarès deux fois à
domino une fois à cadet rousselle trois
fois alors tu vois guie guie ça fait
tellement émission de merde tu peux y
aura la mienne
et si vous étiez un accident
à coup sûr patrick sébastien se faire
pour réagir patrice l'instant mais
attention sans
un dictateur le coiffeur de patrick
sébastien
tu étais un supplice supplice ouais
j'sais pas être obligé de regarder
patrick sébastien savez les cheveux
on est sur un filon la caisse détient
une affinité
la coiffure
c'était une dame qui avait l'air d'une
bourgeoise dans le métro elle m'a
regardé j'ai dit j'ai une touche gelé
suivi comme ça gentiment vie j'ai suivi
suivi il m'a fait rentrer dans un hôtel
film à 17 ans et j'ai seulement compris
à ce moment là que c'était une [ __ ] et
reste c'est comme ça que j'ai perdu mon
plus qu'on le continue et michel
continue à lui mais la suite est
intéressant c est ce qu a tourné par abc
le fait à paul lignon elle m'a dit qu'on
allait rentrer vous avez fait quoi
je sais même plus raconté celle du
japonais avec les trois buts maintenant
japonais
j'étais plutôt vous ailleurs je vous
avouerai que les exhibitionnistes je
regardais beaucoup et il ya eu dans une
chambre un spectacle qui m'a évoqué je
suis pas du but duels et les
surréalistes
il y avait trois énormes [ __ ] qui
faisait sûrement de la rue saint-denis
autour d'un tout petit petit japonais
hilare coucher sur le lit au nirvana et
elle s'occupait de lui comme il
comprenait pas le français elle
commentait et disait alors fait l'uci
fait lui sa enr sail a l'air d'aimer en
garde comme il est content et je regarde
les faits que ça lui fait tous les deux
est parti faire quoi tout d'abord
qu'est-ce que vous avez une question
oppose je comprends pas la regarder on
va regarder le débat c'est intéressant
ils sont les cartes pipi annoncé au
toucher pendant qu'on peut regarder
comme ça
c'est
[Rires]
une question à patrick sébastien moi et
que j'ai envie de baisser depuis très
très longtemps plus chez touquet et
discuter de la famille à belle et
sébastien
[Applaudissements]
la question qu'on a tous envie de poser
linda clitoridienne vaginale
merci tu veux enlever de la bouche
[Applaudissements]
je suis content j'ai des élèves
qui préférez-vous alexandra propre carte
ou carole rousseau y en a une qui me
balancer des horreurs c'est alexandra
elle a balancé comme ça dans la presse
alors que j'avais rien demandé non agréé
carl rousseau peut être vraiment casse
burnes tour pour les pour les ce et rohs
l'arrêt en a compté
pour lui expliquer ce que c'est la chose
voulue par exemple imagine tu as deux
cartouches a tiré bien prennent
jamais de guigou par exemple à elisabeth
guigou oui elle est pas mal il avait
découvert est suffisante c'est qu'elle
est protégée en tapant à de l'attirer de
mai à septembre
alors la veille elle a dit à 29 ans on
peut pas dire tiens je perds
ton peut pas dire je vais me payer la
petite non plus là
vous avez tous plus de 40 ans donc c'est
ça parce qu'on est vieux non mais je
dirais salle
quant à john on sait comment les
guignols vos caricatures avec paula tout
ça je trouve simplement que c'est un peu
dégoûtant d'une certaine manière de me
faire passer pour un maniéré un précieux
et un type qui se passe oui d'abord qui
se branche sur les sur les sur les
jambes des rois jeu c'est toujours la
même chose je l'image que tu donnes non
laïque et fred retard le junior
est ce que c'est vrai que vous êtes
resté très copain avec elie alors il
faut que je m'en attendais il faut que
je vois là je me mets dans la peau d'un
monteur s est pas faite à leur chat oui
alors pour répondre et pour mentir je
dirais je ne pardonne pas et lee kai
sallas si je devais dire la vérité je ne
dit pas la vérité c'est l'interview
manceau faisait tout [ __ ] en l'air
je suis un fan de la gaffe oui ou non
ils n'arrivent pas à mentir c'est dit
mais la gaffe je les rencontre et on a
discuté
il ya une discussion d'arriver en arrive
à parler bon bah c'est sûr tellement il
va pas écrire de la poésie va pas de
faire un alexandrin teiki pas à
l'alexandra qu est-ce que c'est vrai que
vous avez un sexe énorme je refuse
d'appuyer encore sur un vieux poncifs
qui une fois de plus alors là je la pose
à tout le monde la question oui à sa
peau et non mais attention tu irais je
vais poser albert mais je connaissais la
réponse bancaire
votre mère vous engage si vous voyez pas
que c'est le gros mot des trucs [ __ ]
jusque là où jusque là elle s'est bien
comportée
découdra de rein devra donc l'amour
hier a
alors assuré que j'espère que monsieur
célarié rassurer dans quels cas par oui
papa tu as la chance que je dis [ __ ]
non mais attention vous êtes mieux quand
vous faites pas attention à ce que vous
dites
est adjoint au maire oui oui et autres
que monsieur tiberi oui les projets
préparé un petit jingle pour tibéri
écouter
[Musique]
messier
bon ça
j'ai fermé
oui oui a tant fait on tape en train d
or aux gens j'ai entendu que je chie
rate inviter quelqu'un dans un château
qui lui appartient pas au tournoi ils se
les payer château ne sais pas moi mais
bon je veux ton perso on l'a dit la
femme c'est à sa femme wahiba use une
femme qui a un château royal à une tente
non non et non alors question c'est
l'âge de 26 ans va être 26 ou non mais
attendez il m'a demandé un truc
intéressant pour mémoire c'est pas comme
moi il m'a demandé si je pensais écrire
un autre livre oui
je sais tout juste tradition je pose de
l'investissement huitième livre
je n'ai jamais dit que c'était le
premier je me demande où
l'ancien dictateur
à bas ce serait une claire forcément
vous étiez un supplice
la conversation je vous étiez une
infirmité cas l'infirmité sur les veaux
en bas je suis une affirme
philippe sollers je n'ai jamais lu un
livre de comment il s'appelle déjà
je suis totalement inculte et ensuite
parce qu'elle célèbre écrivain français
à une groupe de mères dos et
vous avez appris aussi grâce à quelqu'un
mais vous connaissez sa vie par coeur
il ya un truc encore il ya
il va se passer quelque chose
gachet toujours parce que celle ci parce
que c'est lui
avec moi
quand je me suis retrouvé dans les
permanentes et après j'ai passé les
épingles et après les brosses et puis on
m'a dit tu vas accéder à la mèche
on m'a dit oui tu vas apprendre une
brosse ronde avec ton séchoir jeudi mais
c'est merveilleux c'est un des plus
grands moments de ma vie j'ai pris la
mèche et j'ai commencé à se chauffer la
femme était hyper heureuse comme ça
disait je sens qu'ils sont lourds puis
elle les mettait ses cheveux et moi je
mettais une glace jours et je disais
vous êtes contente de ça et je lui
mettais tous ses cheveux en avant ce qui
fait qu'elle était hyper heureuse que
c'était mais quand vous me fait un
brushing sont lourds montrez-moi la
glace derrière là je remettais et elle
faisait a mis son lourd là aussi donc
elle était hyper heureuse j'ai appris le
mentir vrai bois d'amont sublime de
jouvet balai pour voir ça se passait
comme ça reste est assez agréable prenez
d'amener comme ça mais qui monte quand
même qu'il ya la caution
et elle mettait dans le jean un très
proche du sexe ou la coupe d'europe
je me tirais beaucoup sur la tige parce
que je voyais der dette énorme je peux
vous dire marlène jobert saint martin se
faire épiler ah bon oui à la cia
alors on mettait de la cire sur leurs
cuisses
mais moi j'avais des débuts très léger
de culotte blanche très douce
c'est déprimant quand tu rentres chez un
agent qui disent pourquoi est ce qu'on
va faire de toi mon dieu je sais pas
quoi faire
écoute je crois que le problème ça fait
quand même quatre sans fil que tu fais
pas de demande il n'y a pas de demande
du tout du tout et du sexe au cinéma il
en faut et je crois que j'ai compris
disait-il je pourrai jamais de prendre
dans mon agence parce qu'on ne sait pas
si tu es sexuée
qu'est ce que vous préférez ans vous
allez bientôt prendre
[Applaudissements]
premiers moments de ma vie c'est aussi
les premiers flirts une femme de 30 ans
incroyable vécu énorme poitrine avec un
shetland incroyable m'a collé contre 1
c'était 10 kg à bouhrouz beaujolais
s'étaient tenus par bell simon et pol
pacini ils sont très âgés maintenant et
je marchais j'avais quinze ces gens
avaient un jimmy père série puis j'avais
des cars ville mon temps avec des
boucles puis j'étais un petit nec et je
trouve très très long web maintenant
j'ai 48 ans donc je suis un peu en fin
de piste à cause de revenir main et non
mesdames et elle m'a collé contre le mur
et elle m'a embrassée sur la bouche je
crois que c'est le plus beau moment de
ma vie j'ai senti une langue
savait pas s'il fallait bouger ou aller
plus loin a été immobilisé et ça c'est
un très grand moment après j'ai mis la
main sur les seins j'ai dit c'est pas
possible
et après
lentement de manière inquiète je suis
descendue vers ce continent noir
aussi inquiétantes sur lequel sigle moon
a tellement travaillé parce que tous les
gens qui friment des anges
c'est comment je la prends moi
j'y crois qu'à moitié
et de savoir faire
[Musique]
par exemple les blacks c'est les seuls à
savoir faire tard yann moix jeunes très
très mal au gardien
j'ai ça dans la tête qui par là nous on
sait pas le faire nous on est là pendant
20 années à les observer non c'est pas
peur
[Musique]
qu'on vit pas ensemble
c'est grave ce qui est en train de se
passer il ya l'aveu d'un homme installé
financièrement stable qui fait du sport
dans un hôtel connu avec qui tente avec
moi et qui est en train de révéler ce
que sollers crient à tue tête comme
adamo parce que comme ami laurent baffie
un jour ou l'autre
adamo arrive car adamo a dit je veux
crier ton nom je veux crier ton nous
crier ça mais là c'est vrai c'est vrai
que je vais finir par ne plus aller à la
télé que pour chanter des marabouts ce
que j'adorerais dans le temps c'est un
droit c'est les débuts de la musique
c'est à dire qu'ils avaient précédé ce
café canal plus après on les voyait
toujours prendre un tout petit peu la
guitare et comme ils savaient pas hyper
bien elles mêmes qui ont les enfants
d'affaires mais aux hellènes joissains
pas pourquoi tout comme ça
et pourquoi il y en avait une qui était
toujours flipper en amour c'était
laquelle qu'ils aient toujours mais il n
comment tu fais toi ton couple
immensément bien
c'était quoi c'était pas la lie
laly laly vous pouvez mourir
da vous préférez avoir une tête de veau
ou un bras de 9 m
visé parce que la tête de veau bon
d'accord
vous gardez votre voix c'est de m'avoir
genre vous vous dites bonjour
normalement
vatican même moteur
calé dernière chose que vous faites
avant de vous coucher
je ferai un lexomil
c'est pas très original mais quoi je
vais pas vous dire que ça fait quoi
elle souhaite déjà senti une sous merde
ça sent concerné une sommaire de
ce qu'on fait si je l'avais décidé de
pas me parler de scooter mais brille
donc ça c'est pas vous parler vos pieds
nus qu'en plus c'est de moins en moins
le cas de pas vous parler de vos
origines au calysto pratique pas
la poitrine
les grandit de 17 cm en combien de temps
non maintenant évidemment la police n'a
pas suivi
forcément il ya du nouveau texte qui est
petit est précieux
vous a déclaré une fois je suis à 100
dons sur le manière oui j'aurais pu dire
liban d'où truite saumonée enfin ça
dépend des fois c'est vrai quoi il se
fait partie du clan des jolies il y en a
oui je vous le confirme
non vous avez déclaré au sujet de ce
clip vous étiez tout nu même si on sait
que de temps en temps un type à se
tripoter le schmilblick c'est pas très
grave j'ai dit ça à judy vraiment
garanti pur porc alors donc si vous êtes
chez vous sortez votre chemise physique
cette fois c'est existe peur d'eux des
films pornos non
c'est bien il n'aime pas du tout les cas
de cette pente
est ce que la porno phobie c'est quand
on a peur de l'acte sexuel c'est marrant
ce cas
là
tout de suite c'est à vous qui parlez
nous on n'existe plus à mon avis le plus
vieux
qu'elle est très jolie saisir mais je
vois bien vous êtes à feu jaloux
à vous mais non vous avez vous avez
déclarez vous avez déclaré les premiers
les premiers livres on les écrit
toujours pour plaire aux filles oui
inscrits mais au nom du tout
c'est une remarque je sais pas
vous savez le coup le plus classique
qu'on fait c'est jouer arrivée les
jeunes filles ravissantes qu'il faut
faire dédicacer un livre est la phrase
classique était ma mère a tellement
d'admiration pour toi oui ça a changé il
ya quelques temps et c'est ma grand-mère
landes ou rejeter chez gallimard raconte
cette histoire à ce moment là il ya une
stagiaire qui entre ravissante charmant
et je vous assure qu elle a dit je crois
que vous êtes à la mi-journée arrière
un jour je suis invitée avec greta garbo
on est trois tables et j'admirais
beaucoup un tag arbaud est pris d'une
espèce de folie je me met à chantonner
le pinphone copie source
est ce que ça dit quelque chose je suis
des pieds à la tête oui et c'est la
chanson de l'ange bleu ouais je sais
comment la mélodie voilà un
pile à vous voulez vous faire chanter
comme ça au plus bas à neuchâtel voilà
je chante s'arrête à dogo elles piquent
pas mot est à vous est comme on assiste
quand on fait des gaffes et j'ai dit
j'ai tellement aimé l'ange bleu derrière
j'ai dit je vous ai tellement admirée
dans l'ange bleu elle se retourne vers
moi et me dit je vois que vous me prenez
pour marlène dit à
plus tard je dîne à côté de maladie
vraiment on s'entend bien on s'entend
vraiment bien et elle me dit même ce qui
est assez rare elle me dit venez me voir
j'habite avenue montaigne je crois
qu'elle habitait vraiment un auteur et
je lui dis je vais vous raconter une
histoire tordantes je lui raconte cette
histoire elle m'a tourné le dos elle m'a
plu
quel est le couple qui vous choque le
plus une femme mûre avec un homme jeune
de femme ou un homme âgé avec une
midinette
sûrement pas le tour andy
goode un tricheur nikto fob
niki lauda
venir la phobie denis qui
est ce que vous êtes bléneau non
baîllonné fob
oui alors c'est la peur de bruno bellone
c'est vrai que cette histoire elle elle
et elle est mal partie elle est mal
parti et puis après jamais il n'a pas
besoin de publicité la puce t il à cette
publicité il est archi connus et pour
moi ce qui est important c'est que ce
gamin là je veux pas qu en gris je
voulais dire que j'ai beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup d'amis beurre beaucoup beaucoup
d'amis africains que j'ai vécu des
moments absolument magnifique avec eux
que j'en vis toujours et que je souhaite
que ça dure le plus longtemps possible
et que
je suis bien embêté de tout ça je crois
que je suis pas le seul parce que ça
pourrait donner une image
il faut pas qu'elle existe cette image
il faut la paix faut la paix la paix
absolument la paix absolument la paix la
fraternité absolument absolument c'est
là le seul message à faire passer c'est
la seule chose qu'on soit digne de vivre
et qu'il faut absolument vivre dans la
dignité on est des frères on est pas on
a des confessions différentes on a des
façons de vivre différentes nom et des
frais on est des humains
cette planète a été déglingué par
d'autres que ceux sur lequel on voudrait
aujourd'hui jeter l'anathème
le truc le plus dur que vous avez fait
tous les deux mois j'ai je faisais du
mal à jongler avec des poules naines
les attend des chansons et
services et la bonne vie c'est un
cabriolet mercedes vous devez l'écouter
donc fait chier
vous passez vos anniversaires avec
christine bravo c'est super sympa et
gilbert montagné qu'est ce qu'il ya de
mieux dans la vie que faire avec les
super montagne est
si vous souhaitez rencontrer une rouge
sa forte poitrine
qui a beaucoup de thunes une mercedes et
qui sera vous défendre contre les
méchants dans la rue
et blanc permettra
si vous aviez une baguette magique vous
changeriez quoi en vous
pour le fun il veut les laisser répondre
à
olivier
daguerre
she was inédit le week-end
tu fous je l' ai vu je connais yahvé
barclays qui vous est lavé ses chemises
avec ça ces tâches de mousse au chocolat
comme ça et après vous file edi sac
parce que vous aviez nettoyer ses
chemises elles vous mêmes départ tous
dans un resto ont nettoyé auger a
été influencé par la philosophie
bouddhiste ça
vous êtes mi-régimes nestea ouais
qu'est ce qui vous fascine dans
l'univers féminin justement vous qu'être
fasciné par l'univers féminin
et fille qui rosissent un peu comme ça
mais qui résiste quand on leur parle
d'organes
attention c'était deux mois
c'est vrai il arrive
michel haddad a soufflé louis armstrong
la journée
je regarde la suave d'un triste
c'est trop
j'avais alexandra broeckaert ce à côté
de lui qu'il est très con on est tous
d'accord
et a tout fait pour plus d' abord il est
tombé sur pire aujourd'hui alors ça
obama le sait n ya pas eu bat nominés
garçons
alexandra
s'ils n'ont jamais fait d'histoires
d'arvor oui avec yves rénier dans le
rôle de poivre d'arvor enfin ce qu'est
le plus drôle dans le film je le dis
maintenant parce que la prescription il
baise avec ses chaussettes
il est chaud c'est au
jeudi
est-ce que l'invité mystère m'entends
ministère vous entend pas bien
ses fils de dark vador
c'est bien jean d'ormesson non ces prêts
sur bordeaux qui nous entend vous
tant que quelqu'un n'a pas été condamné
il est réputé innocent alors la
présomption d'innocence et restaurer
c'est à trouver ce que
tu me fait le coup
[Musique]
c'est la première fois je m'étais parce
que j'étais pas tout nu gérer un petit
string
sûr que c'est vrai aussi la première
fois qu'on met un string c'est pas moi
c'est spécial
et chauffants liver
f ils ont quand même quelqu'un qu'ils
ont payé fortune et qui peut très bien
servir c'est christine deviers-joncour
oui elle a servi à pompe et roland dumas
ya pas de raison qu elle serve pas pompé
l'erika maintenant
c'est les blacks
je vais mais je vous remercie ses
trésors êtes là
c'est vrai c'est à moi j'ai toujours
beaucoup fait l'échelle leur usine non
parce qu'à ce moment là si c'est pour
rire c'est pas grave de dire untel est
ridicule ou tel mais si c'est pour lui
faire du mal ou faire de la peine c'est
grave de dire hey lalala 10 q
si vous étiez un [ __ ] vous
pas mal
vous avez dit le dalaï lama que
finalement
on pensait que j'étais dans voici avec
des chanteurs pour faire avancer votre
carrière bien plus profond que celle
qu'il a répondu j'ai pas c'est à dire
que c'est pas facile comme question
dans voici alain danielle mitterrand l'a
vu avec richard gere
ces personnes pour lui non plus pas
oasis
j'essaye turtur revient sur scène oui au
hammam faut que je vous vois les gens
alors on vous a demandé de venir ah oui
il faut que vous voyez aussi d'accord ça
va être difficile s'agit comme tu veux
moi ça me
je parle couramment les deux langues il
ya pas de problème du cannet les
différencie entre une turlute et nouvion
lutte oui ça dépend si tu la vouvoie si
tu l'as vue d'oiseau
est le cas nous ça arrive à deux jours
de l'arrivée du coach arrive dans sa vie
mais sa niche arrive c'était le cpj qui
c'est vrai que tu vas regarde dans les
yeux et leur garde et centre alors
d'arrêter d'y faire mais j'ai
l'impression
je me pose une question donc la première
traversée le bateau chavire à deux jours
de l'arrivée mais ça mais bon toi moi
j'organise tout alors c'est ça mais une
sorte d'exutoire que je sortais je me
mette à crier pour un petit peu évacuer
toute cette peur et toutes ces
souffrances
le quotidien
quand d'être en fait je vais regarder ou
le requin trompette
les attentes de loin une histoire
terrible avec ce cargo les cabrioles
hélas pas le cas où les marins du cargo
oui un chalutier qui m'a accosté et
c'est vrai qu'il ya un bon mois cost et
je sais pas quel était leur attention
donc la stia c'est terrible les gars ça
fait deux trois mois qu'ils sont une
petite blonde même petit matin
10 c'est un petit fou
ça se mange sans faim ça ressemble et
jamais lu de livres érotiques donc il ya
pas beaucoup
il ya beaucoup beaucoup de boulot fall a
déjà vu nous quand même oui je pense
c'est quand même trois histoires assez
extraordinaire que la mienne états
unis personnel et ses passages en mariée
c'est que vous vous êtes attendait
fabriquer tout ça moi si je suis arrivé
tout seul de ces langues et violet
le sentiment d'avoir ramené bien sûr et
puis je rame encore je suis toujours le
comique vulgaire mais j'étais obligé de
ne pas inviter la presse ils vont me
chier dessus mais moi ils paieront leur
place
quand votre père vous voulez vous punir
il voulait bienvenue envers lui il
sortait comme ça sa pochette il a laissé
tomber par terre ils disaient ramasse
moi ça me plaisait pas beaucoup parce
que à chaque fois c'est moi qui prenais
tous les coups dans la famille ouais
donc
j'étais habitué c'est humiliant c'est
plus du million qu'une tarte je trouve
moi ça fait moins mal quand même entre
un trois quart d'heure de ceinture ans
c'est pas mal non je vais effectivement
je prends la pochette 1
n'est pas de tout ça monsieur biya non
non non non sans dégâts
le live c'est bizarre on va saluer
bonjour marie on arrive au pognon à 1
comment ils ont claqué tout ça alors
pour venir à votre père moment il l'en
bouffer le pagne en jcj justement rien
tu vas voir où le maire
attend de voir
il provoque au soubock la caisse
va nous le dire ou où est passée la
thune oui voilà
jacques toucher les biceps de peggy 49
jours sans voir la mer comme axel bauer
touché gersois me dira rien tintin
[Musique]
la jacked orient qui s'approche et
qu'elles touchent les biceps
si tu es sympa comme coop mais je ne
peux pas vous avoir connu à l'époque
parce que vous payez même les locations
de ce qu'ils ont payé le mi-bas rossi
jorge par amp assistance
d'en découdre
mais c'était mieux hier lundi donc je
comprends pourquoi ils perdent toujours
dans les coups de blues
remontée de danser ou jeudi jeudi à des
garçons si tu fais pas certaines choses
à des copines fait le sinon elle ira
voir ailleurs ou bien aux gens de son
coin
c'est la victime et à tête dedans doudou
quoi avant avant il ya des [ __ ] dans
le quartier des landes fourré
valeur
iachini la cus et moi je ne sais pas
bien je divise ou jeudi bisous jeudi
bisous en bas ils vous demandent
d'influencé
roland dumas s'est pas tout à fait
l'histoire mais c'est pas méchant c'est
en tout cas un fiancé et moi j'essaie
d'employés démarre aujourd'hui
si je vais faire comme ça t'as vu j'ai
pas vu mais j'ai écouté hier pareil pour
moi la persuader roland dumas d'accepter
de le vent de chagall écrit serge et 489
voilà
un pochon
et dj par le sexe
que j'entende printemps c'est à dire
quoi faire le guillaume c'est un mec que
je sais pas si ça peut être un mec une
pomme se
donnerait l'exemple à guillaume qui
rappe petit 2 c'est pas parce que attend
c'est pas parce que j'habite dans le 16e
et mes parents me donne 10 mille francs
par mois que j'ai pas le droit de priver
l'injustice pourquoi vous m'avez pas
laisser traîner avec deux arabes et des
noirs c'est à cause de vous tu vois
pas ce que vous êtes rester puceau
jusqu'à 22 ans oui mais oui jusqu'à quel
âge comme il était plus haut de deux
mois
normal treize 13 ans + 13 hors norme
masure 22 je vais rentrer il avait 13
ans à risque
à des judokas qui arrive à s'auto sucer
je pose la question si je mens bien des
questions
non à fleury mérogis avec des femmes et
depuis fleury mérogis j'ai pas être trop
eu le temps de penser à ça mais pourquoi
pas
mais si vous avez une occasion rare de
christine s'essouffler jeu de la vraie
vérité mais j'ai pas je les connais pas
tout ça c'est là je sais pas comment les
raisons que j'ai trouvé un truc qui
s'était persuadé l'hôte de vente des
bombes atomiques
vous le trouvez en arabie saoudite dans
un palais alors je sais pas si c'est le
bon chiffre de 30 mille mètres carrés
beaucoup paris maison
mais quand même année au salon il ya la
métropole est chargé ne
lui s'en va genève en voyage d'affaires
alors il part il vous dit qu'il s'en va
pour une semaine ayant bien un mois
après ils voulaient seul mois deux mois
renchérit je t'ai jamais fait des trucs
comme ça
c'est toujours mettre le cadreur
je suis pas contre bien des aravis un
séoudiens n'ont pas aimé les femmes
aiment traite de [ __ ]
quand on me pose la question comment
j'ai pu me conserver physiquement aussi
longtemps c'est une mauvaise nouvelle
mais il faut pas d'homme il faut pas de
sexe alors c'est une très mauvaise
nouvelle regardez hier web les pierres
ils avaient c'est la forme de la
déformation
si vous fait le plus rire dans la vie
qui me fait rire vous c'est gentil de
mazet n'y ait pas les âmes si vous avez
plus sexy en vous
êtes quand même toujours un peu extrême
droite un peu antisémite quand même
enrico non halal à ne me parlez pas de
ces gens là avec leur nez crochu et tout
ça et tout le pognon qui gagne est au
royal et retournez dans votre pays le
pen il allume le poste il sait pas
salut vous avez vu mineur vous mais que
des mecs top et voilà mais comment se
fait-il qu au canada les hommes ont des
coups comme ça
si vous aviez une choix sur une île
déserte il faut préférer faire l'amour
avec une fille très moche ou un mec très
beau
[Rires]
parce que je veux rester tout seul
et mesurer combien 5 pieds 7 donc un m
soit ça tu dois de gallons par jour
la phrase qui me supporte pas d'entendre
c'est quoi cet accent dit merde
j'étais à refaire votre vie vous
changeriez quoi moi j'aurais voulu être
chanteuse et danseuse dans un cas pareil
les milliardaires elle veut faire strip
teaseuse c'est beau à qui tu me fais
penser à monsieur de fursac moi je te
jure est il obligé de s'appuyer
bienvenue du jour mais
je préviens la chaîne que je ne suis pas
sûr d'arriver au coût de cette émission
et c'est la première fois que je ressens
cela vous avez cheveux courts la wii
pourquoi parce que j'ai découpé
si vous étiez sur une île déserte
imaginé il ya un mec c'est très beau et
une fille très très laide vous
choisissez quoi
mais j'aimais touche
elle aime la dépendance amoureuse c'est
vrai plus que l'autonomie vous aimez la
dépendance amoureuse ce que dans la
servilité
c'est le rêve mais il ya très peu de
mettre à la hauteur de la sq
le lieu idéal pour une étreinte à
l'époque vous aviez répondu les bras je
suis très brave omar gedi
expliquer comment tuer bras j'ai demandé
comment les bras
alors si tu veux entre entre les bras là
il ya une place moi j'ai pas le temps
c'est vrai un très bon mais ça avant moi
un bon maire non
il faut nous le ciel
aubervilliers c'est
[Applaudissements]
bel
est ce que vous êtes porno fob sais ce
que c'est prono x imagine je ne suis pas
ne pas supporter le porno c'est la
première que je vois qu'ils connaissent
à du tartuffe déconne ou quoi
je vous êtes sade au château m'arriver
est ce que vous êtes sac à dos
est ce que vous êtes piano fob oh je
sais moi ça
je sais en plus elle est ma foi c'est
quoi qu'elle nous fasse elle a peur du
mari de barbie
catherine on n'a pas un bout de la
première hollywood là la première à
hollywood une jambe
verniory free
virginie je lui dis
qu'est ce tu ferais quand malgré 24
heures arrive mois 24 heures honnêtement
oui j'achète un appart
et l'a42
[Applaudissements]
adriana la semaine prochaine s'il vous
plaît par les italiens j'avais parlé
français aussi un peu
moins six français
très mal pas du tout vous parlez souvent
bien
la langue qui est parlée en slovaquie
moi
peut-être que vous pouvez gagner un
deuxième un deuxième baiser le taux de
chômage en slovaquie 5 millions pour
cent à kamal savons nous serrer la main
bises ou
serrage de rein serrage de mains
alors votre petit ami de shakira
slovaque pardon il était resté là bas
lui ont les boules bien et là ce soir
yes l'admirent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est ce que si vous le trompiez vous lui
diriez
si christian un jour il rentre à la
maison à madrid et vous trouveriez avec
une autre fille est-ce que vous aurez ce
que vous auriez honte
vous pensez à la scène là oui moi aussi
tout le monde que tout le monde pense à
la scène
américain time qui dit que vous
ressembliez à aleg valaisanne vous avez
la moustache un peu la moustache de
phoques c'est vraiment génial gaudi dont
qui voulait savoir
que sont faits dans les bacs en comptant
les jeunes le vendeur est en projet
montredon du tout comment les parents
peuvent réagir quand on leur dit je vais
changer de visage où je me souviens pas
de votre ancien visage je veux pas
mettre le look mais pour voir comment
sont elles
qui auriez-vous aimé si vous n'étiez pas
vienne folie elle a écouté un
j'aurais voulu être humoriste un
problème a fait peine arrivé à la
télévision mais
voilà
un physique on est péplum mais c'est toi
je trouve qu'il a vraiment serge alors
de serre ges que tu peux faire un gros
plan de survie dans la sphère un péplum
meiway clatot j'ai
tout le temps
dit j'aime beaucoup thierry ardisson par
exemple à l'acte et les vaincus dans ses
montants des voix pour par estelle mal à
vous sortir votre
petite bouteille de champagne
bon dernier coup de coeur alors dernier
coup de coeur qui me réussit pas mal
vous allez vous marier
peut-être c'est sa gonzesse taccoen
congress
déçu non non non les coups pleuvent
bluff
kimberley
messieurs prenez mu bonsoir
merci de merci de venir
du monde en parle
c'est sur le marché des changes
internationaux va taxer l'argent qui va
pas spéculer à la france bat il y aura
plus d'argent qui viendra en france du
tout bon à la merde bah oui mais voilà
il faut savoir ce qu'on veut mais dans
quelle époque quand même un bon
c'est beaucoup plus fort que vous moi ok
donc je j'ai pris un risque en venant
chez vous vous l'aurez noté par aof
enfin on va voir alors je vous posais
une question vous allez m'en vouloir
mais celui ci est obligé de vous la
poser parce que quand on a j'ai eu des
conversations téléphoniques avec votre
entourage pour réparer cette émission on
m'a dit il faut pas parler à edouard
balladur de ses origines turques parce
que ça va l'énerver c'est alors je vois
pas non excusez moi je continue puis je
vous sais de la parole je comprends pas
parce que des fois on vous reproche
d'être hautain d'être distant et en fait
vous êtes un travailleur immigré oui si
on veut
bonsoir
vous embrasser roger hanin vous
embrasser par edouard balladur
on peut dire de trades roger non s'amuse
en bas bien sûr 74 ans
quand j'étais petit c'était coursier
pour des pour des prostituées pour des
pots et pour des mac et vous rêviez
d'être mac en fait ce qu'il faut savoir
à oui ça c'est un scoop énorme c'est que
le rêve c'est vrai projet c'était
horrible vous auriez fait un super match
en plus il dit les mac mac m'aimait
beaucoup il est plutôt si alors elle me
donnait de l'argent que j'étais comme si
j'avais toujours beaucoup d'argent dans
les poches c'est du joli navarro
edouard vous ennuyer pas à vous restez
avec nous oui je vous écoute on est ravi
que vous soyez là aussi je suis ravi
d'être là saturé vachement pas exposé à
leur premier chagrin d'amour c'est roger
vous posez la question à poser
j'ai apprécié sa plaidoirie
mais c'est ailleurs les a réunis ce soir
j'ai été un peu sûr de moi un peu vent
en poupe un peu et c'est ce soir c'est à
dire pratiquement quinze ans après je
suis pas du tout dans le même état
personnel que j'étais il ya quinze ans
ça vous paraît très très très con ce que
veut dire mais bon ce soir j'ai le trac
ce qui ne m'est jamais arrivé pendant 15
ans
dernier coup de poing dans nos coups de
poing
et c'est sur un ring dans la vie non je
crois que c'était dans la vie bon vous
c'était beaucoup pensent qu'une claque
up se bat c'est sympa
c'est affectueux
bon et noir j'ai su que j de vous poser
la question à vous aussi est ce que vous
avez envie de vous suicider une fois
dans tout le monde on a envie géré comme
un emmanuel berl 95 comme
ça n'était pas assez important pour sa
chaloupe autobiographique ah non moi
c'est une longue fresque à 3 marié plein
d'enfants par assistante merde
ça sur aaron et je t'emmerde se range
pas des baronnes je vois sa première
histoire de barron's ne vous en remettez
pas mais pourquoi mais moi j'ai jamais
vue de ma vie dit il vit pas que c'est
un plouc non
il avait déjà dit qu'elle voyait
mitterrand mais qu'en fait ils croyaient
vachement à l'astrologie qui voulait
faire une chaîne une chaire parts dans
deux d'astrologie à la sorbonne jugé que
c'est du pipeau tout cela ils me sont
tombés dessus à la taper
en face de panafieu est-ce que vous avez
déjà couché pour du boulot
on va c'est à dire que là comme on ne
prête qu'aux riches mille fois c'est à
dire que je passe ma vie et je me
demande d'ailleurs comment je suis
encore
annoncée depuis que j'ai dit à une
émission de télé que j'étais copain yves
bertrand delanoë que vous n'êtes pas
gentil avec moi
avec ça
regarde pas ça je suis de gauche je ne
voudrais jamais à droite
vous dites la voiture c'était une sa
bulle son havre de paix et alors ça
c'est incroyable il écouter vraiment
pink floyd dans la voiture oui les
couteaux pink floyd ça c'est dit j'ai
vécu là c'est celui qui m'a le plus
étonné depuis dix ans mitterrand gecko
de pink floyd bill feuilles supertramp
les bee gees
ils chantaient des chants
vous manger de la nourriture végétale
fabuleux c'est très joli et c'est très
bon vous êtes pourrite ofaj en fait oui
j'achète d'aider des fruits je les
oublie et six semaines plus tard il
commence à devenir bonbons et est-ce
qu'on peut éventuellement t'envoyer des
aliments
avec danielle mitterrand à un couple qui
était bâtie sur le respect mutuel c'est
ce que vous dites et puis avec anne
pingeot une véritable passion amoureuse
quoi vous le saviez vous vous étiez au
courant parce que les tous les
journalistes étaient au courant
apparemment mais ils n'ont jamais dit
aux gens qui lisent les journaux mais je
crois que c'est l'honneur des français
de savoir faire ça on a beaucoup de
défense mais pour planquer nos
maîtresses alors
on est bien trop vite
et puis
s'il vous plaît
oui c'est ce que vous étiez jean tiberi
vous feriez quoi françoise
je briserai cette reprise ray les genoux
trans'oise
salle qui tue vous étiez françoise de
panafieu ou feriez quoi
nous montrer les fouilles de
taxi 3 c'est déjà écrit dans la tête de
l'udc ouais c'est tranquille c'est un
bon boulot maintenant je crois que ça
roule quoi faut pas tomber dans le
ridicule et puis jean luc besson c'est
un maître le chien intelligent vivre l
attaque si les extraterrestres
on se fait serrer par les keufs comme on
dit on devient vite un arabe voire un
boulot tout de suite tout de suite ah
ouais tu te regardais vu samy naceri là
là là je suis retrouvé avec les entraves
aux pieds les mains notamment dans la
cage sans chaussettes et puis quand tu
es dans le car est content mène à
l'hôpital pour voir si tu arrêtais pas
malade tu as une bonne ronde jette sur
la gueule et puis on dit sale [ __ ]
ben voila moi je suis habillée par la
redoute mais je suis tranquille dans les
commissariats
la chose qui vous plaît le plus dans le
sexe forte ouais ouais qu'est ce qui
vous plaît le moins les trucs attache
états comme ça mais macha
abondamment écouter sa vie je crois que
nous aurons jamais d'aaland surtout
vous faites vos affaires entre eux et
nous avons fait nos affaires exactement
le genre de comportement que j'ai envie
que mon film déclenché
cela j'ai envie qu'on sorte des salles
avec des ans
alors ce qu'on voit dans votre film s'en
[ __ ]
l amour
est ce que vous êtes fait souvent four
et
[Applaudissements]
vous savez québécois
est ce que vous aimez turluter dans
votre salle de bains
mais j'aimerais pouvoir le faire et vous
monsieur lutte et non pas encore est-ce
qu'il y en ait une traduction française
qui est drôle d'être sûr lutter ici
à lyon d'une pizza sens aurait voulu
fait en effet julie extraordinaire c'est
pour ma foi je vois comme ça ce cas vous
avez votre col de veste et tout sens
dessus dessous la pca premier avec
lequel
vous avez jamais fumé de pétards n'ai
jamais tapé deux garçons vous n'êtes
jamais utiliser de godemichés nom
faisait beaucoup de choses à apprendre
encore
je vais vous dire votre éducation est
resté avec nous on fait une teuf après
si vous étiez une arme un clitoris est
ce que ses larmes quand même qui l arme
secrète au plus vif et la loi sur la
terre ouais suivent est une arme parce
que quand on peu pressé sur la détente
bien sûr tipi c'est vrai oui allez-y
c'est une émission libre ici j'ai dit
vous savez ya pas de problème à les
faire des pires verra comme ça on sera
tous combien de temps j'allais bien que
c'était pas mal
[Applaudissements]
depuis le début vous monsieur al fayed
parler de complot de meurtre organisé
par la couronne britannique aidée par
les services secrets anglais américains
et français et quel serait le mobile de
ce crime ou de ces crimes driver le
mobile de ce crime c'est un racisme
absolue est la personne qui a organisé
qui organisait cela et qui a payé de sa
poche c'est le prince philip
lorsqu'il était enfant il a passé
beaucoup de temps en allemagne
il y avait un mariage avec deux généraux
d'hitler dans cette famille ça suffit
comme explication et cette personne a
grandi dans un environnement nazis
façon vous les accidents de mercedes ça
vous connaissez je fais un bon vol plané
j'étais sur le bord du fossé j'avais la
gueule éclaté je suis ouvert j'ai encore
la cicatrice ici j'étais cassé de
partout je saignais il ya un mec qui
s'est arrêté qui m'a fait [ __ ] patrick
sébastien à merde j'ai pas mon appareil
on a une éducation très libre sans aucun
interdit donc moi j'allais dormir chez
mon copain alexandre qui me faisant
cracher sa chaussette sale cent fois
passé pour pour le prouver que je
l'aimais assez bien
non ça sera vraiment d'accord je vais le
faire je vais faire
gérer cas - les chaussettes
autour de pierre il ya une ya une
malédiction au début j'ai pris en
rigolant ouais on rentre de gala un soir
j'écoute piaf j'enlève la casse edge
mais la radio je retombe sur piaf à la
radio je me prend un shoot un feu rouge
elle explose je prends un carton bon je
sors de l'hôpital une semaine après et
je jette la casse est déjà fou par la
fenêtre puis voir et à une station
service médical je suis trop con je
reprends ma cassette et jeu et je fais
100 m j'ai les deux pneus qui explosent
mais peut-être que les didier était en
train d'écouter pia de reynès
musique a été composée par marguerite
monnot qui a composé qui a proposé en
trop dans un sens oui et l'hymne à
l'amour faites gaffe à ce qu'on pense de
pia on va à
la responsable socialiste d'entrevue sur
la gueule
interview télépathie première question
répondent et 31 cm
deuxième question
tu peux répéter à la fin la question
non non je trouve pas que sébastien soit
ringarde
dernière question
linda hardy
qui par exemple s'est mal comporté un
garçon comme dugarry n'a pas été à la
hauteur de son statut je pensais
on a un coach qui est qui et qui
derrière nous et qui eux bah oui comment
il va votre coach là lazano ça va un peu
mieux il a eu un petit malaise dans la
nuit de mercredi à jeudi après le match
oui oui bon match et d'écouté piaf aussi
comment il va être choisi ce candidat là
heureusement il n'y a pas de là
franchement si vous pouviez m'éclairer
moi c'est ça me rendrait service mais
qu'est ce qu'on fait pour être dans un
monde meilleur qu'est ce qu'on fait
ce qu'il ya les écarts qui sont
présentement
de plus en plus grands il ya vraiment
des gens qui sont en train de crever la
dalle et y en a d'autres qui s'en
mettent plein les poches donc qu'est-ce
qu'on fait concrètement le rpr le bidule
du
qu'est-ce que cela coince à l'épaule et
qui soyons en train de travailler quoi
merde je ne gagnais pas votre poitrine à
l'époque maintenant c'est fini ça c'est
pas possible c'est pas que j'aime est
pas moins poitrine c'est que tout le
monde en parlait donc au bout d'un
moment ça me chante moi c'est bon
il vous lâche plus là
ça que j'ai dit non non j'ai dit non non
je te fais non c'est un petit pew
chevènement ah ouais ouais je trouve
qu'il est courageux palaiseau le bon
dieu qui l'a sauvé une fois il ya
d'écouté bien fou si vous écoutez bien
phu tho été très gentil avec ta femme tu
me l'a dit d'être un gentil taille et il
a une conception de l'adultère qui est
terrible il me dit toujours su sais
c'est pas trop et puis dans le cul ça
compte paul
ya quelqu'un qui disait et drucker était
tellement gentil quand on est donné un
coup de pied dans les couilles et vous
demander si vous n'êtes pas fait mal
on pas que ça manque de filles un peu là
non ouais tiens vous
venez vous asseoir à côté de ça manque
un peu de fil ça vous embête pas
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes prêt à vous je vais regarder
ça pendant tout le jingle kate winslet
pas bougé je vais vous dire j'ai regardé
laurent aznavour mais voilà johnny
johnny
il extraordinaire chirac
cabrel charme à
jeudi l'amour ça rend la peau plus douce
de moi quand je fais l'amour après j'ai
la peau plus douce assez marrant ça
c'est plus moite aussi et surtout
grâce à l'adn on sait maintenant que lou
17 n'est pas la fille d'yves montand
patrick bruel
si tu me quitterait
je souffrais
pierre bellemare c'est ce qui attend les
quinze fois
il va venir oui je sais mais on va le
vendre
comment vendriez vous un vibromasseur
qui se recharge sur l'allume-cigare
chers amis oui l'objet que je vais vous
rendre à doit absolument être utilisée
sur un parking et en aucun cas
pendant la marche des véhicules en effet
à partir du moment où vous avez branché
dans une liga le vibromasseur que je
vais maintenant vous proposer
tout est possible le nirvana peut
arriver et donc il est impossible de
jouir de nirvana cyr en même temps est
en train de doubler nos deux chaînes de
2 h sur le taux est ce que vous préférez
hitler ou staline
et en connaît qui se dit [ __ ] c'est
pas d'ambition vous suivez tout ce qu'il
dit la patte ubuntu parce que là vous
nous faites un peu un politique vous
savez ce qui se passe quand on fait un
homme politique non mais je vais voir
d'abord vous êtes mosaïque et serge et
puis à ça surtout
c'est la punition c'est i muvrini
même plus tard par jour en ce moment
mais là on peut pas répondre par oui ou
par non faut donner un chiffre
reconnue s'est dit plus
il y aurait 10 - 2 - 3 je partais
pas trop inquiète toujours c'est ce soir
faut qu'il soit brillant ouais faut
qu'il soit bon rien il y est toujours ça
il m'énervait parce que ça vous ça veut
dire qu'il n'avait pas confiance en moi
bien je dis vous savez je m'appelle dany
brillant lors que voilà c'est resté
comme ça voilà vous avez été brillants
ils jouent toujours des rôles de jeunes
anconina en fait un des plus vieux que
les rôles qu'il a incarné s'était jamais
l'air bien
que là je pouvais le dire quand même
bien sûr je suis dans 53 47 à 40 me soit
là non oui avoue trouver ça un peu
géronto
et préférer dany brillant quel âge
aidera à vous c'est une question d'âge
brillant vous avez quel âge a votre avis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous allez me répondre en chantant c'est
sympa à faire payer le cachet j'ai quand
même du mal à ça
dernier coup de foudre j'ai rencontré
une autre fille
mais celle là elle avait un chemisier
rose
elle voulait savoir quelle était mon âge
elle s'est trompée mais peu importe car
je crois qu'ils se passe quelque chose
entre nous ouais
mais coup droit
c'est tout à l'heure
la question pierre bellemare comment
vendriez vous un vibromasseur qui se
branche sur l'allume-cigare frédéric
diefenthal moi j'en ai rien à [ __ ] je
fume pas
dites-moi prêts à vous monsieur prénom
je suis marié monsieur
papa au paris lagardère et non voilà
donc on parle pas de la guerre d'algérie
mais on évoque d'une certaine heure les
vols d'une certaine façon
pas de va ne déplacez pas de pas de
conneries sur le sexe du rap abidjanais
voix lasse un peu
plus à moi ça il faut pratiquer chez
vous mon cher ami
qu'est ce qu'on fait tous mes cheveux ce
matin je fais pas le même geste c'est
pour ça ouais
c'est pas monsieur cas du suma
serait pas que fabius était un peu trop
à gauche quand même
si
vous avez de quoi rouler un pétard
évidemment
pétards début de soirée après je passe à
autre chose comme ça mais je crois que
vous aviez arrêté la coca aurait aimé
lui et non non non non
monsieur prévost je suis marié je sais
ça fait trois fois
la place je me suis au prévôt je suis
marié seule fois
je suis
chez moi j'ai vécu en suède mois pendant
cinq ans mais cinquante années on se
fait jeter à rasteau comme
braquo tous les soirs avec les landes
derrière le là c'était un set j'étais
jeune et c'est mon frère qui m'avait
obligé de vacances
il ya philippe des toubitri
parce que vous avez un problème avec les
relations avec les hommes avec les
garçons
bon d'abord je dois dire que
si je dis que c'est un ami c'est un ami
c'est jeudi c'est mon amant c'est mon
amant
un jour leonardo dicaprio le vrai des
eaux nardo appel et mathieu baird lui
dit voilà je voudrais dîner avec vous
deux fois il vous a plu c'était moi
un
ami débarque à l'improviste chez vous ce
qui vous ferait le plus au monde qui
découvre sur l'étape de nuit le livre de
claire chazal ou un godemichet
il y en a un qui est un outil de plaisir
paraît-il way you lie et l'autre qui est
bon enfin bref donc oui non plus plutôt
le livre de claire chazal vous préfériez
qui voit le livre de claire chazal
quelques du nord qui voit plutôt le
godemichet
la mère d'eurostar a déclaré collard
toute façon la seule chose qui
l'intéresse c'est son image dès qu'il a
eu le rapport d'autopsié il a balancé un
hebdo il est toujours là pour la presse
nous quand on l'appelle il est jamais
libre et il a essayé de dresser la fille
aurore contre moi pour 110 nations avec
tak tak
voilà
dernier coup de foudre dans les coups de
foudre oui de foudre
qu'est ce qu'ils ont tous à ma famille
il aurait sûrement plu c'est vrai moi
vous êtes marrants les mecs quand même
un peu ce soir c'est ma femme bon c'est
vrai c'est donc moi j'ai pas trois mois
vous allez me dire ce que vous feriez si
vous étiez j'étais président de la
par exemple je ferai le retour des pin's
parlant d'accord oui elle a plus de
pin's parlant de tf1 avec sa voix avec
la voix d'alexandre debanne voilà un
sénat qui a dû 15 que j'avais prévenu
retoucheur je mettrais gens normaux en
taule oui
c'est vrai je sais beaucoup de scènes de
sexe du palace ex bombay mais
c'est vrai que
si vous voulez vous asseoir
est ce que vous êtes fétiche au nom
exhibo oui à adamo
est ce que vous êtes porno ça veut dire
qu'on regarde et que cette tendance
étant je crois mais pour nous c'est bien
oui
vous donnez sauver un animateur de télé
laurent cabrol laurent cabrol pourquoi
parce que je suis une femme du téléachat
oui et si vous deviez sauver un
animateur de télé qui s'habille toujours
au noir
c'est pas le mec qui fait
j'en suis fière
alors aujourd'hui bon vous êtes viré on
peut le dire c'est pas le mot est un peu
triviale mais bon ça nous est arrivé à
tous après faire lourder parce que nous
on ne s'est pas fait légèrement
donc on annonce sur la tl l'arrivée de
laurent gerra ouais c'est bien ça voilà
de marc olivier fogiel qui vient de chez
moins bien de canal+ pourquoi vous dites
que c'est moins bien pasche ne l'aiment
pas
madelin
un cohn bendit de droite
parce que là vous étiez bon quand la
main mais c'est vrai qu'une chose que
j'aurais aimé faire je peux vous le dire
maintenant c'est lé brossette et grand
malentendu de la vie c'est ça
valérie lemercier
très grosse tête j'aurais pu aller aux
grosses têtes mais tous moi si j'avais
dû salon mais je vous ai invités vous
n'avez jamais voulu venir ah oui c'est
moi qui pas l'inviter s'était
j'étais timide
en 93 vous épousez arielle dombasle
ça marche toujours
alors au départ le film devait s'appeler
maman j'ai sucé papa non non c'est pas
vrai
c'était une boutade
c'est pas mal
ah
merde c'est pour ça obligé de maddock
démenti à chaque fois passer à la télé
si vous êtes une [ __ ] alors j'aime pas
du tout ce mot parce que je trouve ça un
mot qu'on emploie canton enfin les
hommes emploi quand ils sont un peu à
cours d'idées alors qu'un [ __ ] ont dix
ados
on s était mignon un seul homme c'est
que c'est un compliment pour les hommes
ah bon ah oui ben je prends pas comme ça
oui on le voit
vous fiez pas si
je vais plus loin que vous c'est un
brevet de qualification
vous êtes considéré comme un compositeur
à part entière et pas seulement le
chanteur spaghetti quoi elle sortit sa
baguette et ça ça
[Musique]
commentait
mathieu dans les yeux ouverts
est ce que vous croyez au petit signe du
destin oui oui oui je pense qu'elle vous
a préparé un petit signe du destin c'est
quoi par exemple pour voir ben on va
quand je pense à quelqu'un il peut me
téléphoner c'est pas automatique
dix ans
moi je pense à bruce willis serait
curieux m'appelle jamais non mais c'est
peut-être parce qu'il n'a pas mon numéro
vous croyez la fidélité j'essaye mais en
même temps je suis pas déborder
propositions donc c'est vrai ou c'est
plutôt une obligation la vénalité ghosn
a une obligation quand même si quand
même des propositions de temps en temps
ce que dit gad elmaleh dix ans quand on
a un petit peu connus on se demande si
les filles sont amoureuses de vous de la
colonne morris ouais ouais vous appelez
ça une colonne morris vo
c'est que tapie revient dans le football
parce que c'est une bonne nouvelle pour
football ça bernard gardon sympathique
attachant le seul problème c'est que de
vouloir toujours avoir raison il se rend
même pas compte des conneries qui dit
donc
dernière question est ce que vous avez
de plus sexy en volant mais pour le
moment parce que ça m'arrange les
quelques kilos en trop que je trouvais
ça sexy et je l'espère
[Applaudissements]
alors de grâce sexy maintenant mais
comme je pense que la première question
un barrage les quelques kilos qu'ils
montraient
des corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux